WHAT'S UP, it's your boy Super Gamer 5, WELCOME last episode
I beat the hardest level with ZERO DEATHS (amazing) in case you're not familiar with me, my name is PewDiePie
I have never died in a video game ever in my life (so true). So I beat the hardest level and
You guys weren't impressed (how dare)
Apparently there's a DLC in Crash Bandicoot of a map that was deleted from the game :O
Because the level was too hard
BOO HOO
The game was too hard, and it's too fracked up, STAHP
*ear rape*  STAHP KIDS
Stormy Sn more like BORE ME. That's right got em.
Alright here we go, oh it's just like Dar- it's the hardest level EVER
Apparently, apparently the developer was like. Oh, I didn't really know how to make the difficulty
uuhhh
Not spike, okay?
Wow, this is so hard
This is practically impossible
OH MY GOD HE'S THROWING TOXIC
(wha do i do)
This is virtually impossible.
(get rekt m8)
WOW.
What does this do?
INCREDIBLE.
This is just like-
DARK-
Oh My God, how fast do I got to be? Jesus.
(take ya time pewds)
I got to time my jumps now? That's to- fuck you. Fuck. You fuck you
(ripperoni)
Zero deaths by the way, thank you.( ✧≖ ͜ʖ≖)
OH wow, that was superduper difficult you guys are right all along
hardest level ever- PFFT
MY...
D-IACK
Yeah, it's the hardest level ever
When does this game get hard? I don't get it. I genuinely don't get it
I think you're all a bunch of crybaby pussies who needs to suck on your mama's teties.
Here we go, Crash Bandicoot
(sploosh)
This this- (whoah!)
WHAT
I wasn't even near it!! Whatever zero deaths that does not count OBVIOUSLY does not count
( ͡°- ͡°)
No, you fucking twat
Really? =~=
*ded* (woah!)
Why do I have to fucking redo everything if I fall down? Fuck you. Jesus Christ..
I swear the only reason they deleted this was because it's too easy (sure pewds)
As to as- eh? (I don't know)
FUCK YOU
Didn't even hit me >:3
EASY
THIS GAME IS EASY
what the hell is-
give me that check point BOII
Gimme dat checkpoint BOI
Da fuck is that
What is that thing
I- FUCK IT
THERE IT IS BOIII
EASY
ZERO deaths, thank-
(oh shet)
that's-
fucking-
(woah!)
( T ʖ̯ T)
EASY
OH MY GOD
Hell yeah man. Look at this shit. I got skills for days..
son.
Fuck you, biiirrdd.
DON'T touch me old man
been dodging old men from touching me all my life
Shoutout to my uncle
I'm Joking. He wanted my sister.( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
IM JOKING
(serious pewds activated)
Come here bird. Give you back massage bird. Don't molest me man.
( ͡°³ ͡°)
Aan-
(woah!)
Dafuq was that shit
UUGHH
(woah!)
(rants in different language)
This lamp is so fucking hot I'm so sick of this lamp, it's got nothing to do with-
What's happening in the game, but goddamn I'm tired of this fucking lamp being so goddamn fucking hot.Jesus Christ.. >:c
*imitates* Imma lamp I'm gonna be super hot st-
Shut up =~=
Piece of shit (shots fired)
Watch me 'beat' this level blindfolded okay?
*burps*
Legit I could be playing this with my ass and still beat it of course.
Hell yeah, look at that shit boy
EA
ZY
GAME
SO NERF (what?)
Nerf Crash too strong
this fucking platform piece of shit-
EASY
Abidjan yeah (I don't know he is really saying)
That's it my man my man man :3
You want back massage man? There you go man.
I-I-ya welcome
I don't even wait for the stairs..
cause it's too eas-s-s- (laughs)
I don't need stairs in the game.
Awe Jesus
(whatcha gun do?)
All right
Don't touch me old man. What did I say about all men touching them or me okay?
OH
a little too early
That's okay
(Woah!)
God fucking damn it. That's okay. That's okay. It must have been a mistake somewhere
Look at this shit boy
(Trying to imitate Aku Aku)
COME ON MAN. Give me a CHALLENGE man! FUCK YOU MAAN
(laughs)
I wonder which one of you whiny sons of bitches is like "Oh this game is level is too hard-
we must delete it from the game"
͡° ͜ʖ ͡°
Otherwise I will k- fuck you fuck you
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?!
Come here boy- come here son
Boom (woah!)
(frustrated sigh)
It's not even funny, okay?
Shut up
(Uka Uka: Game over)
Okay
Whatever. I don't give a shit.. I don't give a fuck :c
I was actually born inside this video game, not a lot of people know about it
It's a legend about..fuck.
Okay there's SHIT SON
(oh snap pro coming thru)
FUCK OFF
(and there it is again)
Look at this shit boy,
PTHRA
RESPECT RESPE- FUCK YOU!
WHY WOULD YOU COME WHERE I AM?!
Easiest Stupidest Jump
o.O
*imitates Aku Aku*
respect respect rEsPeCt respect RESPECT respect respect
(to many respects dammit)
Jesus Christ RESPECT (oml)
respect (pewds stahp)
respect (stahhp)
respect (STOOP) RESPECT (KILL ME)
MY NAME IS-
OOH RESPECT
My name is- Mahna Mahna Mahna mahna
GET UP
( ͡° ʖ̯ ͡°)
Can you fucking fuck stop - just stop
Here it is- HERE IT IS
Okay, okay
Let me look at the pattern let me study the pattern just LIKE DARK SOULS.
You got to learn to move sets, okay?
flip
*Crash starts dancing*
(mlg pro)
That was so easy because I'm so good at games Dark Souls "specifically"
Oh my God
Come oUT, fuCK
What is this then? uugH. Okay, Look at the timing look at the timing..
FUCK OFF
Where am I? Where's my FUCKing checkpoint? Where's my fucking checkpoint?
My name is Jeff! FUCK.
Where's my fucking checkpoint? (this again) Where's my fucking checkpoint? Where's my fucking checkpoint?
=~=
*tries to memorize move set*
Hmm not TOday. Mr. Spiky boy
*this shit again*
(oh shit)
(oh fuck)
TTAAAHHH,
CHECKPOINT GIVE IT TO MEH, GIVE IT TO MEH,
BOI
*memorizing move sets once more*
OOOH OH
Respect the wamen oh, dis gon' be tough
(so hows a everyone doing today? Good? okay.)
(woah!)
FAAAN FAN
FUN FUN. HELL (I know that's not what he is saying)
Oh my God
*serious pewds activated*
( ͡• ͜ʖ ͡• )
(° ͜ʖ°)
( ‾ʖ̫‾)
( ͠° ͟ʖ ͠°) (dammit say something)
FuUCK OFF man (thank you)
Geezus..
Give me a life..  :c
*dies in 3*
*2*
*1*
(rip)
Fuck you, piece of fucking shit. Go- fuck you. Go fuck yourself piece of fucking ass
(just repeating what he says) okay bye